[music playing]
NARRATOR: In Bimini,
Bahamas, a team of experts
are hoping to entice a couple
sharks for an experiment
and get more than
they bargained for.
[music playing]
They're testing if sharks
can detect magnetic fields.
The answer could unlock a major
mystery about how sharks find
far-flung, food-rich
volcanic islands
and whether the island's
naturally magnetic lava
rock is involved.
For this open water
experiment, they
arranged three powerful
magnets to the right
and three non-magnetic
controls to the left.
A big hammerhead glides
over the aluminum control
without a glance and
heads for the magnets.
Hammerheads ignore the aluminum,
clustering around the magnets.
The nurse sharks have
a greater response.
Nurse sharks are
drawn to the magnets.
The sharks are agitated,
possibly by the magnets.
[music playing]
That was fantastic.
That was great.
So many hammerheads down
there, all over the place.
A bunch of nurse sharks.
The nurse sharks were
playing at the magnets.
Really neat dive all around.
Yeah so that dive was crazy.
We had nine hammerheads there.
We got what seemed like
countless nurse sharks.
What we saw was
that both the nurse
sharks and the hammerheads
did respond to the magnets.
So what we can
take away from that
is that those weak magnetic
fields that are locked
in volcanic rock are
something that the sharks
could detect and may be
able to use in navigation.